how you do my name is jammer chambers
and I'm Malcolm Bray and this is Tamara
Jessa sorry about the lights and
location and the framing and the
microphone and everything everything we
believe how this would stack we got like
I'll get a reference yeah we are in
Airport right now in Baltimore back to
Chicago from kinetic hunger that was 11
I saw spider-man homecoming was ready
fellas
yeah which is like the most spider-man
that was clean in like 15 years because
I mean we had to Sam Raimi you know
Tobey Maguire tombow they kind of
captured him in his adult years but
night he wasn't white I like mature he's
old enough but he wasn't like mature he
was like constantly like flipping over
banana peels and really goofy I thought
that was so amazing but also how old
were we are the stammering boy how we
were like I know I was like 13 so you
had to have been running 12 11 12 yeah
okay why you're having this is Tamara
Kovac and then we got the Andrew
Garfield one was just too cool for
anything and that even like like he
didn't have like a moment to like even
take a breath to grieve over Uncle Ben
death
I feel feel like that oh oh you'll get
like amazing amazing spider-man with
Andrew Garfield all right I did I liked
them I think to be honest now like now
that I'm older and wiser and I'm looking
back on it I think it's just because I
like Anton Garfield and I
Emma Stone and I think their chemistry
was so bad I wouldn't even fathom what
it was but they were really dating
cheating right you're right so they
weren't even acting yes what are my
homecoming like do we do spoilers wait
oh that's a good question I've been
trying not do spoiler okay then I'll
just kind of dance around like in
Spanish yes but let's just say like okay
this fighter man like you get like more
of his like coming with Ames it's like
no this is a Spider Man you know he's
got experience out there but you know
he's trying to become a bigger hero and
you know you got Tony Stark they're kind
of like guiding the way right and
there's so many moments in there where
you see where you still or you know kind
of dependent on Tony Stark like guidance
he's trying to break away from and so I
always thought that was an interesting
dynamic yet daddy starting the hair yeah
trying to like you know show the youngin
how to be a hero right I wish I enjoy I
like that you kind of put smack dab in
the middle of spider-man's
life edges kind of story that we all
know and love there's not a ton of
there's nothing like backstory vitamin
you don't get there like the origin
story I guess yeah I like that yeah yeah
and it's not really needed because we
get repeated so much and we in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe this version
we already get what his motivation is
sort of because we saw him in the war
you know he already knows Avenger
success and him being at Euro War Powers
like his motivation is to be like the
other girls that you know have saved the
planet ain't going around you know
saving things out of treatment and he
wanted a big bundle community where he
wants to save the planet
- so yeah angry I think his motivation
is that he she's got a taste for it and
he likes it and wants to do it and and I
think it's great I I was gonna say like
this the main focus less on accident
more than common which the hi I'm going
to be like controversial here y'all
I thought this was funnier than
guardians of the galaxy I can get you
all hilarious you know what yeah
actually like I'm laughing for me
anyways yeah it's like very situation
comedy kind of like Three's Company
going on yeah yeah yeah
coming back on our door he'll be waiting
will you I think if your pants off but
he was so good at college with excellent
yeah
you know he made it work like he was
affecting his voice like he made himself
seem like he was still a high school I
bought it I did too and then when the
next movie we maybe that'll go away a
bit and like good sure he's growing
right right right
and like you know if you're worried that
he's going to be a spider bully as you
know I rock yeah Rob Walker yeah I think
he's going to mature we're gonna see
like a more mature spider-man and it's
going to be earned
and oh oh is it yeah you guys look at
what we have it some time it is look at
this this is for you guys we did it for
you I guess there was a small bit of a
crunch using the Marvel Universe it's
already been so built one using Iron Man
but I like that story I I mean to use if
that's the story of Miss effective yeah
no no Tony Stark you know the concho
yeah yeah what I want to be yeah I like
that I thought that was a cool way to
take it so that we can have to do the
whole backstory side of it which was
already seen so much turn one thing that
I loved was the villain Oh yo like oh my
Gucci damn well that was a hairy choice
I heard there's this moment in there
where instance Owen and yeah Oh like
like
and gritty like and don't have
motivations it's not like I am evil now
you know you like doing it with a
purpose
they were like great cinematic moments
yeah again I don't want to spoil
anything right right this is something
that you're going to happen yeah but
discipline and and believable and it's
just really good there's a really good
moment with them where we find out some
things that reveal the whole theater
gasps and there's no exciting wood every
one of the theatres on the same thing
and like it happens in such a way it's
like where you think it's one thing but
then you're like oh oh oh sad like I
love Michael Hughes eyebrows I know you
go get me a dress also Aunt May's so
well
they do some really good work with
addressing her like youngest yeah her
young people hotness her milkiness yeah
million oh yeah it felt like actual
Queen it's not like actual coins it's
not like oh you know the like there's a
cast you know like a bunch of white
people in and not it's like everybody is
like actually looked like he was like
pretty much the only you know I get
there that it's pretty realistic yeah
right yeah growing up in Queens I give
him like even more of a dynamic in the
story I agree yeah yeah and without a
meal plot point yeah without it being a
pot point just like this is the world
this is how this part of the world is
you know yes
what is Marvel major look so easy they
do such a good job
yeah it was really good work come on DC
come on y'all yeah Wonder Woman was
pretty good girl just and justice in
trailers um I am NOT is justly to me
right up front about it oh it looked
rough it was the past was like a little
less moral character art like he's like
faced with a decision and teach decision
he makes really makes his character more
definitive where he currently is so I
think he'll be presented with an
opportunity again later but the decision
that he made at that moment this showed
where she Kirby was I think that was
more power like they had some more
profound it made him you know like yeah
yeah you aren't quite there yet
yes but when you get there it's going to
be so work right and it made me excited
is even it yeah
Marvel is queen Bible is king large
empty all of it
oh and for inference DC is like a sad
gorgeous gorgeous hurry up I'm into it I
don't be am I can do you I grew up with
nothing
now and like parking gas
like what is that nonsense what's the
library we wouldn't it's unclear exactly
yet yes Black Panthers are I do that was
a blast it was really fun to see it with
the whole channel awesome crew yeah and
Andre was there back there calm would be
Oh wonderful you were at connect on
thanks so much yeah yeah alright thank
you
[Music]